little busy at the moment
you know now that I have doesn't matter
alright
royal is this skip this skip has been
this skip has been ordered sealed by the
divine prosecute
you must have clenched this is a little
trick I picked up in coral stand our
sign your righteous light on those that
would flee your justice
show me where evil lurks and I will
deliver retribution two lights has not
supposed to be all right
whatever I'll follow this one follow
that light and see where it leads you
then meet me inside the refectory go go
ah the accomplice welcome
tourists release her sure now
find this Daedra this is going to end
you
she says in Austria you work your life
away you might as well spend it on
luxury so she uses about one roll of
toilet paper every time she goes to the
bathroom she says if it's gonna don't
understand oh but this week I could make
it business well they will get
there's been how many years that they
had to go into the background that's a
toilet paper that was at the kitchen
hello
are you here that you're gonna get more
money Billy and stop complaining about
the toilet paper well okay well I ever a
good day just gonna hang on bunny I'm
sure sure I'll call back one way or
another it just seems like what would
actually happen okay should we just go
big I'm working honey what he's used if
I'm Peter
I usually don't so we will do is once we
will complete with this one we will go
this guy's wasting no time
Diaz and Charlie it C as in Charlie okay
then
B David then you randomly sing words to
distract me from what's actually
happening so apparently he
they transfer a different three thousand
dollars from his wasted no time at all
he transferred that from my savings
account to my checking account and he's
going to edit the HTML and make it look
like I'll make it say that it was a
transfer from Microsoft you know like
what happened right now like I do
apologize to you for the inconvenience I
just got an update from the billing
diversity while they were top you don't
that you can be row right now they don't
you sometimes okay like they're saying
while they were transferring you $300
certainly because your computer it's so
slow and due to that tree ransom
there is a huge mistake has been
performed by them while they were
transferring you $300 but by mistake in
your freedom community credit union
account which is ending with 1 3 3 7 has
been you know yeah okay what you can see
with the today's date like twenties 28th
of January 29 2010 II description what
you can see can you see Windows transfer
and the online transfer from the Reaper
team of $5,300 so there's a huge mistake
has gone by the billing department team
bring you the $300 but by listing extra
5000 rupees in your account bring you
the money suddenly like an extra
Oh
in your account
five thousand dollars that came in your
account along with the three hundred
fifty three hundred dollars that came in
your account your money is only three
hundred dollars that you're supposed to
get so much now the extra which is five
thousand dollars that has came in your
account that amount does not belongs to
perform while I was from Turing using
money but in the